you didn't even want to direct a guy you
know I carry on about the odds you said
that a moment ago about how he didn't
want to direct the god no you didn't you
didn't want a director you thought the
book was kind of crappy and that it
would be impossible to remember the book
a big part of it yeah but half the book
is about this lady who has this kind of
collage Abul problem and the guy was
gonna operate on her and then he made
love with it I thought it was sort of
sleazy yeah and I and those days when I
was young I wanted to be like you know
Fellini or write beautiful Godard and
and be an artist you know so when when
we had this little company to do
personal films with these younger guys
wall became very famous they would see
me Francis we gotta make some money
we're broke they're gonna change do this
book you know this gangster book just do
what they want don't argue with them and
taught you to do that Paramount Pictures
why do you think they chose you well you
know I add Lee when they first got the
story there had been two or three movies
about like gangster mafia there was one
with Kirk Douglas called the Brotherhood
and they were all flops so all the big
directors turned them down hmm and they
decided to make the Godfather very
low-budget right and a young guy who and
I had been known as a screenwriter so
they figured they get a free rewrite and
and then also I was italian-american so
they figured if it caught a lot of guff
they would say well he made it very
unlikely that I would get that job but
looking at you it's true if you had won
the Academy Award for writing Patton
right you would won that already and so
you think if your movie studio say hey
listen maybe we can get this guy to
direct it and he'll write it that's
right have a good script I remember this
script it was very hokey you read the
script he said this is awful I can fix
this I'm going to sit and do it and you
were doing it strictly for money well I
didn't want to do it because I wanted to
make the conversation I had written the
script of the conversation and I was
trying to get money for that and did you
say to them if I'll direct this mafia
movie for you if you give me the
financing for a conversation well I
wasn't even in a personal game to say
that
I mean I mean a they hired finally we
really just need him I was George Lucas
who said to me Frances we gotta get some
money in here you're the only one who
can make it so they hire you to make
this film and you're like oh this book I
mean you had to sit there and read the
book and figure out what the hell can I
pull out I found then I came to admire
greatly Mario Puzo and when I met him he
was just the most one neatest man you
know and the soul just simple and and
wise you know so I really I really
really came to like him and admire him a
lot what am i yeah I was just gonna make
a point about that what amazes me about
you as a director is that you stick to
your guns number one you know most guys
want a big name in their lead roles you
already had in mind who you wanted the
studio was trying to get you to get big
names and you stuck to your guns which
is not easy to do when you're a guy who
doesn't have much luck you need the
money I was very much the rumor was I
was getting fired every week they didn't
like my casting because you know I had a
lot of new actors no one had heard of Al
Pacino we didn't have the money for
stars so we had to find the new kid when
it comes to casting they wanted the Ryan
O'Neal for Mike for Michael yeah I know
Redford even Wow
and when I said gee they don't seem they
don't look like Evans correctly said but
the Sicilians can be blond and blue-eyed
which is true but people don't think of
my I said but he's kind of have like
since he's a kid who doesn't want to go
and be a gangster he's gotta have it
like on his face that he's Sicilian
imagine if you didn't stick to your guns
how different that movie would be maybe
not even the successful and the script
was said in in modern than the seventies
it wasn't in the 40s right it's cheaper
to make a movie when it's not period
right so I came on this young guy who
had no cloud at all said I want to make
it period in New York they wanted to
make it 70s and like st. Louis or
somewhere cheaper did you go off a
budget yeah I did the movie cost the six
and a half million dollars and they in
the budget was they thought they were
gonna do more for three million dollars
so did your life dramatically change
after a success like that I mean do you
just become the guy who can get in
project he wanted anything yes and no I
mean I was hit by a success that I never
imagined and it was that I became a
different kind of I became a big
important Hollywood director right and
you even said originally to the studio
Martin Scorsese would be a much better
choice as a director than my father too
yeah you said it but he's like was four
years younger than me and they said
who's he no no no no you so show you
ended up doing the Godfather it would
have been weird if anyone else had done
it well but he would have done it well
but they you know I didn't want to do I
didn't believe that The Godfather was
the kind of story that could be
serialized I thought it was a drama and
it was over and that was the end and
Michael you know kind of corrupted
himself and that was the story